this is CNN breaking news
and a new development in the School
Admission scandal as Conan O'Brien
stands at the center of a controversy
over his son Dustin O'Brien who was
admitted into the Xavier Institute for
mutant education and outreach despite by
all accounts not being a mutant
ridiculous of course he's a mutant he's
my son
we caught up with founder Charles Xavier
or Professor X his application seemed
perfectly fine to me
ability to fly telekinesis although his
sports photo should have raised my
suspicions it became clear rather early
on that compared to the other amazing
executive students Dustin was far from
extraordinary he have no mutant powers
[Applause]
leave me alone
I did what any parent would do what any
parent would do O'Brien apparently made
payments in the amount of $200,000 to a
Dean at the Xavier Institute a dr. Otis
Bach Mayer
I hope lots of people I can't remember
also named
Dean Bach Meyer is a man who O'Brien
denies ever speaking to I am gonna make
this very clear read my lips
at no point in my son's admission
process did I ever speak to a Dean Bach
Meyer okay that's it it sounds
convincing but so does this okay so just
to confirm I you Dean Otis Bach Meyer
and you'll get my kid into the school
for free but it remains to be seen
will they need to make room in jail for
mr. O'Brien and will Dustin who to his
credit has been working on his shot be
playing for a basketball team in the
newly completed gym at Xavier Academy
the Conan O'Brien field house what a
jerk for CNN I'm Jake Tapper
[Music]
[Applause]